good morning John it's Tuesday February
2nd and this video comes in four parts
five parts the first part is that I can
never figure out how to do parts videos
because I always forget what parts I'm
doing and I always come up with new
parts in the middle so probably more
than five parts but warm no two part two
of the new intro what you just saw some
people think that it's too impersonal
some people think that the music sucks
some people don't like it at all some
people love it I want to hear what you
think about it because we're considering
maybe making the new intro maybe making
a new song the new intro maybe doing
different things with the new intro
maybe whatever from my personal
standpoint let me put in a vote for
short when you have a 30-minute long
sitcom I kind of like a 30 second long
intro so when you have a three minute
long video you kind of have to have a
three-second long intro part three
Emilie Emilie Keith do you know who you
are a certain nerdfighter named Harrison
wanted me to ask you if you don't have
any other plans if you wouldn't mind get
married two of them and uh and if you'd
say yes my theory is that he will stop
emailing me about it
so that's my vote my vote is for yes and
you can do whatever you wish you being
an independent free thinking person
hopefully congratulations are in order
part four the disreputable history of
frankie long banks yes this book is by
one of John's friends one of his friends
in the his writing group in fact I read
the thank yous at the end and John is
thanked and I've finished this last
night late after reading it way way way
too late into the night and loved it so
if you're looking for a good book here's
one I think it actually kind of had a
lot to say about nerd fighting and in
several different ways part for the
haengsuk
so well I've got this pink sock and I
don't really know what to do with it so
I was wondering if anybody had any ideas
of what I can do with a haengsuk this
was made by a nerdfighter and given to
me on the nerdfighter tour well it's
pretty amazing so I wanted to do
something cool with it and I wanted to
know if anybody had any ideas or what me
and the Hank song could do together
besides of course it's embarrassing
moment suck up a theater which has
already been done was this part for
you never remember what part it is
anybody know I have no idea I think
actually that this is part five
so john dftba